The Great Flood had some really cool
visual effects and at the same time just
horrible, horrible. I don't even know
what happened here. Regardless, my
favorite effect is this one. It's a kind
of set extension, but a void. I made my
own version and to be honest, I like
mine a lot better. I start off with a
shot that I then track. I then modeled
the very, very basic geometry of
essentially what I want to remove. Then
for those areas, I need particles. And I
figure I should probably play both of
these shots that I made to completion.
So, wow, look at this. Such good visual
effects. I know they probably have like
a limited time budget, but I don't. So,
I get to gloat. This video is sponsored
by Squarespace, and we're going to talk
about that later. Imagine a cube that,
let's say, is black and we spawn a whole
bunch of particles on it. For each
particle, I'm just going to find the
nearest edge and then push it towards
that so it's concentrated on the edges.
Add some like variation and radius and a
bit of noise. And that is the effect.
For motion tracking, I'm going to use my
camera tracker add-on. Select the video
to turn it into a image sequence. In
this case, I have a video and it is now
images. Great. do an accelerated track
that uses the GPU and just hope that it
works. Even though I'm supposed to mask
the actor, you can track yourself, but
something something promo something
money. And here we go. Okay, good
enough. So, we have our camera. We have
a point cloud. It's not the densest
thing in the world. And I'm just going
to roughly orient it to the uh world
coordinates. Now, if I go into the
camera, you can kind of see the camera
motion. We're going to select our camera
so that I can actually see the
background. That's going to be a movie
clip. Indeed, we have a track. This
point cloud for the most part is pretty
useless except for kind of the areas
where it outlines the uh car. I do have
an operator for this called the clean
operator which will get rid of most of
the junk but still not too useful. I now
want to model the scene which involves
you know modeling. So let's kind of take
our coordinate system and I want this
like XY to be put somewhere useful maybe
at the corner of this column. So this
like world parent that moves everything
I'm going to set this to move relative
to the 3D cursor. So the world origin in
this case, shift it on the X, shift it
on the Y until we're roughly in the
corner over here. Let's play a bit
forwards. Yeah, that looks pretty good.
And then finally, we need the scene
scale. If I add a plane, by default, if
you look at the dimensions, it's going
to be 2x 2 m, which unless I'm a huge
man, which maybe I am. This seems pretty
small for 2 m. So take this again with
the world origin scaling, and I'm just
going to scale it, which effectively
moves the camera and everything closer
to the center until it looks roughly 2
m. Now, I find the easiest way to model
things is with wireframe mode enabled,
so we can kind of see through. Minus one
on the Y, one on the X, so that the
corner is exactly where it needs to be.
And now do the worst modeling job in the
history of modeling jobs. I'll do a
little bit of it here. Really, all I'm
doing is I'm outlining only the parts of
the scene that we would indeed see. So,
you can go to the last frame and be
like, ah, you don't need to go much
further than this on the X. And ideally,
we model everything, but like who cares?
Okay, now that you have your we'll call
it our good enough scene where we have
like the rough geometry since we're
doing that idea where the points move to
the edges. We don't want extra geometry.
In other words, extra edges it can go
to. If I look at edit mode, you can see
a single surface that just represents a
section of the floor has a lot of extra
geometry. We can get rid of that just by
hitting X, going to limited dissolve,
and all of the sudden it is a single
engon. Instead of doing this like one
patch by another. So this is a limited
dissolve. This is a limited dissolve.
What you can do is A to select
everything and then run a limited
dissolve. And now we can just do our
geometry nodes, right? I guess we should
apply scale is a good idea. So control
A, apply scale. And then I'm going to
distribute points on the surface on
faces. And all of a sudden, yikes, we
got so many points. In fact, we want
many more. So I'm going to make 200 of
these until this coats it quite nicely.
Let's maybe take our point radius and
make it really, really tiny. So divide
by five. Bump this up even more. And now
we have our surface coded in points. To
see this in reference to the original
geometry, all I need to do is I join
these together. And now I have my
original surface with its points.
Remember for every single point, so
let's say this one over here. It should
identify its nearest edge on the surface
geometry. So in this case, obviously
it's going to be this one. And then it
should, you know, gradually move in that
direction. And that should especially
apply to points that are much further
away. So let's say this one over here.
It also has this as its nearest edge,
but it should move a lot more than the
one that's close to it. Well, geometry
proximity is the easiest way to do this
cuz I can find the nearest edge of what
the original surface that I'm inputting.
And that will not only find the nearest
edge, but the position on that edge. Is
it at the top, the bottom? Somewhere in
the middle? Now, if I was to set
position, in other words, you know, move
the point cloud. If I was to use this as
the actual position, you can see it maps
to the nearest edge. I don't want that.
I want it to go some of the way. So, we
can take the position and I can mix a
vector with, let's say, the original
position before we even moved it. Here's
before and after. And then how much that
moves by. I mean, I guess it should be
randomized, but it should also be based
on the distance. Luckily, we also have
this distance that tells us, okay, we go
to the nearest edge. How far away is
that? And that could somehow be related
to our factor. Let's throw this through
a map range. And then, what do I want to
say? Well, I definitely want this to
affect the factor. And I also don't want
it to be so like harsh as it is right
now. Let's use a smoother step. I want
to make sure it gets close enough to the
edge so we can see what's going on. So
something like 6. And then let's add a
bit of a randomization random value. As
I increase this, it moves more towards
the edge. So let's do 0 to one to start.
And maybe since we like 0.5, let's hover
around there. So like 3 to 7 before
after it just kind of breaks it up a
little. Another thing is this from
maximum that you can see kind of affects
the range of it. Maybe that in itself
can be randomized. And maybe instead of
a random value, I have that be more of a
continuous noise. I'm going to take this
noise texture. I'm going to throw it
through a map range on its own. And
noise texture, especially when we have
normalize enabled, tends to hover around
0.5. It's a random number between 0 and
one. On average, it's somewhere in the
middle. Let's go from 04 to 6. And then
instead of one, let's go 1 to three.
That's pretty good. So you can almost
see these like waves where the noise is
affecting it. And then what do I want
for the noise? Should it be high
frequency? Should it be low frequency?
Maybe low frequency with some detail and
some roughness. And maybe it can go a
bit closer. So like 6 to 1 and a half.
But I think this is way better than the
initial distance was. All of this set
position nonsense can be a node group.
Ctrl G. Move to edges. And then maybe a
second thing we can do is we can add
some additional points that aren't
affected by this like edge gravity. just
smaller points that fill in the space.
Let's distribute points on faces again
with a different seed. This one should
have way more, maybe like 3,000. I join
this together, which makes it totally
covered, but maybe these points that
aren't going towards the edge have a
much smaller radius. Let's randomize the
radius and call it a day. Right? So,
instead of the radius being 0.01, I'm
going to keep it as simple as a random
value. Yikes, that's big. Multiply this
by 0.01. So, it goes from a maximum of
0.01 and a minimum of zero. And then one
thing I like to do is right now this
random value if I look between a sample
of like zero and one you know some
points are going to be here around zero
some of them are going to be around one
but generally it's going to be equally
distributed right there's going to be as
many points down here as there are up
here. What I think I prefer is I want
most of them to be small and then a few
outliers. So we can bias this instead of
a 0ero to one randomization. I'm going
to throw it through a float curve. So
right now this is uniform and then maybe
what I can do is I can heavily bias
this. So most of them are quite tiny. I
kind of like this linear cuz it's easier
to control. And with isolating these,
let's see that before and after. Kind of
intense, right? So let me make it not as
insane. So these points are randomized,
but a few of them are going to be much
bigger. And I want to take this same
idea and maybe put it up here with these
smaller points that we're distributing.
Join these in. These have a much tinier
average radius of 0.002. Let me just
kind of take a third of this, let's say.
And now if I isolate these, there's a
bunch of tiny ones, but some of them are
a bit bigger. Well, maybe since we're
using this randomization twice. Let's
turn this into a node group where we
affect kind of this average size
multiplier. So, this is going to be 0.01
and then we have the same thing up here,
but it's like 0.003. Call this our
random size. And maybe we should break
apart this joint geometry. So, we have
our points and then we have our surface.
So, we have some points here. We have
the ones we move to the edges. And then
we have this extra stuff. Let's get rid
of the extra stuff and then kind of put
it at the end here with its own join
geometry. This incredible tutorial is
brought to you by Squarespace, the best
place to make a website. Mine,
cgmatter.com, made hosted with
Squarespace. The purpose of that one is
to host free nodes, blend files, a
membership type area, and that is only
possible because of Squarespace payments
that lets me have payments, you know, be
integrated right into the site. Other
things that are useful is the asset
browser cuz I have a lot of images, a
lot of files. I can host it there.
Thirdly, whenever you're filling in
stuff where you know what you're going
to write, it's basically documentation.
Directly integrated AI can just fill
that in for you. You can try it out.
Just head over to Squarespace, make your
own website, and when you're ready to
take that and launch, you can use my
link down below in the description to
save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or a domain. We have our
surface, which we distributed points on,
made them a certain size. We did that
again for this other point distribution
that we moved towards the edges. I
joined these contributions together. We
then have our original surface and I put
it all together. The nice thing about
this is now that we've separated these
joinings, I can apply a material to each
of them. So, this gets a material. This
gets a material. What are those
materials called? Well, one can be
called the void and then one of them is
going to be called the points. The
points gets the points and then the
surface gets the void. Our points are
going to be a simple emission shader
that are going to kind of be this
orangey viery color. And then our void
can be pretty black. This is more like I
made a powdered donut or something like
that. Um, how do I want to remedy this?
One thing we can do pretty easily is
take the emission and bring it down. But
that's still a bit I think there's just
too many points is what's is what's
going on here. Let's make it half as
much. And then our ones on the edges,
but they're a bit too big. So, let's
make it 0.007.
Bring down the number of points a
little. And then one more thing we can
do is our points that are everywhere. I
like the size, but they're kind of like
too perfectly distributed. So, I think
finally for the radius of at least this
one, I can throw it through one final
multiplication, which is one final scale
factor. And then that multiplication can
be by some like noise texture, something
pretty continuous. Noise texture goes in
here. I wanted a bit higher contrast. So
remember noise texture averages around
0.5. I'm going to go 04 to 6. So now you
can see these nice patches that are you
can kind of see the pattern too much. So
I'm going to bring down the scale. Add
detail. Add roughness. This is the
before and the after. Just adds that
nice texture. As for the emission
shader, I think one cool thing we can do
is they're orange, but maybe some of
them are like yellow or a different
color. Because these are points, we can
actually use the point info node that
tells us the position of the points, the
radius, which is really tiny, and most
importantly, this random, which is going
to be some number between 0 and one for
each of these. We could use this for the
strength of the emission, but also I can
take this random. I can check where is
it greater than some threshold. So
something like.99. So only 1% of it is
going to get a different color. And I
can mix between two color options. This
should be a mix color. We have our
orange and then the 1% chance can go to
this like yellow which connects here.
And you totally can't see the difference
at all. Maybe there just aren't enough.
So let's do 95 instead. Yeah, now I can
see them a bit better. Maybe they should
be a bit more orange or red or
something. I think one of the last
things we need to do is obviously this
looks fine, but it doesn't make sense in
the context of some of this should be
the actual footage and some of it should
be the changed area. I'm actually going
to take this geometry that we made and
separate it into two parts. One part is
the one with all the particles and one
part is without. Maybe this big face
right here and then this back wall and
this back wall. Whatever we select, I'm
going to run a separate by selection. So
that this is now its own separate object
that's going to get its own material. It
doesn't need its geometry nodes. You can
see some areas have points and some
don't. But then our key issue is this
section should be projecting the movie
clip. We do that by creating a new
material. I'm going to call that
projection. And its only purpose is it's
going to put the footage back in. So I'm
going to bring in the movie clip, which
I guess needs to be an image texture.
Import in the movie clip. It's going to
be something like I don't know like 300
frames or whatever. Turn on auto
refresh, which is going to let it, you
know, change every single frame. So
there it's playing. And then obviously
it's jank. That's because its coordinate
system that it's using is UV
coordinates. We instead want to use
something called, so these are UV
coordinates. We want to use something
called window coordinates. I look at the
image, I use windowed coordinates. And
now we get that nice, in this case,
repeated projection. You want to set
this to mirror so that the seam isn't as
obvious. Either way, I don't want to see
any of that junk. So, let's hide that.
How do I do that? Viewport display
passer part two. Yeah. So, as I play
this, we move out. Great. And then this
area is nice and tracked. Amazing.
Obviously, there's a lot of fine-tuning
to do, but that is a pretty good start.
If you get any pokies, like right here,
this is poking out. All you need to do
is just roughly edit it. So, I'm just
going to take a point. I'm going to
shift it. That is what's called a fix.
These faces shouldn't be here. So, I'm
going to delete those faces. And
instead, I'm going to use this
projection surface. So, I'm just going
to do one of those. That's good enough
for the purposes of this. Great. Uh,
okay. I think one final thing is this is
a bit too shiny, this black void. I like
that it's reflecting some of the
original footage, but let's bring up the
roughness and bring down the specular.
And in compositing, we're going to make
this look fine. You'll see in the
original, I have these like glowing line
things that I didn't explain. The way I
did them is I basically took our
geonodes thing. I did a duplicate. This
duplicate, we don't need the geonodes
for. So, we just have this geometry
again. And then all I did is in edit
mode, I isolated the edges that I wanted
this effect on. So, I don't know, I'm
just selecting some random ones. We'll
call this good enough. So, what you do
is once you select the edges, we want to
isolate them. I'm going to hit Ctrl I to
invert the selection. And I'm going to
delete only only edges and faces, right?
Something like that. So now we have our
edges nice and isolated. And you can see
they make these loops isn't correct cuz
they don't close. But something like
that. And then this can get its own nice
uh geometry nodes. All I need to do is I
need to make a curve that pulses and
glows and whatever. I'm going to run a
mesh to curve. And the only reason I do
that is then we go back into a mesh. I'm
going to use my tube node. I dare not
use the default one. I hate it. What is
this? This is useless to me. So I'm
going to use the free one from my
website. You don't need to pay a thing.
You can just grab it from cgmatter.com.
Take this curve tube node. Connect that
in here. Now we got some beakness. Make
it tinier. Even tinier. And now once we
set up our scene, you can see we have
our nice edges. They're the boundary
between the projection and the void
thing. Add a set material node to our
border curves. That should get a new
material that I'm going to call edges.
Put that in there. As a baseline, I'm
just going to use a emission just so you
can see the nice boundary. That'll be
orange and glowing and whatever. But the
trick to make it look interesting is it
needs to do this pulsing thing that you
see. And I didn't do this with geometry.
That's just pure shader magic. All I did
is I stored an attribute of the spline
parameter which tells us how far along
the curve are we. In other words, 0 to
one, we loop it. 0 to 1, 0 to 1, 0 to 1.
So that's useful information. I'm going
to call this our spline. In the
material, you can bring in this
attribute. So I called it spline. Little
hard to see, but you can see it starts
black and then it goes to white at the
very top. If I connect this to the
emission, it's going to get, you know,
stronger as it gets to the end. But to
get this to do a nice looping, literally
all I did is I multiplied it by a
number. Let's say it's 10 iterations.
It's going 0 to 10. And then the trick I
always talk about is throwing it through
a fraction, which I need to zoom out to
actually see. And now it goes 0 to 1, 0
to 1, 0 to 1, 10 times 0 all the way up
to one. And then it's immediately zero
again. I just want to add some
smoothing. So I'm going to use a color
ramp. No, I'm going to use a float
curve. Even easier. have this be
symmetric about the middle but with a
bit of fade. Something like that. Before
and after. I'm going to take this
output. I'm going to make it much
stronger. So maybe it's like three times
as bright or whatever. And then the
final trick to have this move over time
is remember we're taking whatever we put
in 0 to 10 and then we make it a
decimal. If I use a addition, what I'm
essentially doing is I'm offsetting it.
If we have this animate over time, we're
good to go. And because I don't think
there's a time node, as far as I know,
I'm just going to use a driver. So hash
frame gives us the frame number. So,
frame 1 2 3 4 5 whatever. You're not
going to be able to see it cuz it's so
fast. It's going wahoo wah wah w. You
want to take this, divide it by 20. And
you can see that's a pretty good speed.
Maybe divide by 25. The bigger the
denominator, the slower it will go. And
then to make it less cringe, just make
it much much thinner. The reason it
looks weird is cuz it's huge. So that
no, even thinner. Like it should be real
tiny. All the good stuff happens in
compositing. So speaking of which, let's
do a composite. Only things you need to
set up is in the render tab under color
management. I'm going to set this to
standard just because I'm projecting the
footage and I don't want to mess with
it. And then for the render passes, uh
the main important ones is I want
ambient occlusion. I definitely want a
cryptomat maybe by object just to keep
it simple. So I can say do I want to
affect the edges, the original footage,
the floaties. Let's do a thousand sample
render. It's going to go surprisingly
fast. Yeah. Yeah. Look at that.
Especially with motion blur and
everything. Let's get like a a frame
with a lot of movement. Like that one
over there. That looks nice. So, let's
go over like the super basic version of
the compositing I did. The first thing
you're going to see here is that we have
the render, but I can't really
distinguish. If you look at the alpha,
it's all white. I can't really
distinguish between the objects. So,
that is what the cryptomat's for. I'm
going to add a cryptomat node. If I
cycle through this to pick projection is
pink. We have the column. We have that
little thing over here. I'm going to
select the projection, which you're
going to see is going to isolate that
area. And if I add in the image, we
don't need to. It will show that part of
the image. I'm going to take this mat
and what I actually want to do is I want
to invert it. I want everything except
the footage. The reason for that is all
of this stuff that we made is perfectly
rendered. It's nice. It's sharp. I mean,
yeah, there's motion blur, but it's
perfect. Whereas, this was shot with a
piece of iPhone potato. So, I want
to match that. It should look like this
is also shot with a piece of iPhone
potato. In other words, if I want to do
something like a pixelate, for example,
where as I bring this up, you can see,
oh, it's more pixelated. That should
only be affecting the render, not the
projection part of it. Let's do a
pixelate of two. So if I zoom in before,
after. And then another thing that
really just makes it look disgusting. A
trick I like is the Kuwahara filter.
Let's just start with the Kuahara
without pixelated and just see what that
looks like. So that's just pure mush. Go
to end panel, go to options, turn on GPU
if you have a good GPU, that'll make it
faster. So you can see as I increase
this, just pure mush. And then with the
pixelate as well, maybe it should be
after. Yeah, that's mush. So before,
after. And now I want to say only apply
this to this part of the render because
this also breaks our our like you know
the part that we like our projection.
The idea now is I'm going to mix color
between the original stuff and then this
stuff. I'm going to copy my render
layers over. We're going to have this.
We're going to have the pixelated
version. And then the way we mix between
them is with this invert color. So let's
see what that looks like. So now if I
flicker this on and off, you can see the
mush, but it's not affecting our
footage. We also need to match the black
so it doesn't get too bright or too dark
or whatever. The darkest part of this
image is probably down here. And that
black is more like a brown. If I click
and hover over this, you can see all
these numbers, these RGs and B's are
actually the value. You can see that
never dips below like 0.05 or 006.
Whereas our render render can go down to
0.005. I'm going to take the brightness
and contrast. And I'm just going to add
some brightness to it. And the amount of
brightness I want to add is just so that
our mush turns into around 0.05 value or
luminance. So let's do a brightness of
like.3. What does that give us? 0.04. 04
almost. Let's bring it up just a little.
Yeah. 0.05. So this is the before and
the after. I don't know if that comes
through on YouTube, but it makes it
blend in a bit better. I'm going to
bring it down just a little just as a
stylistic thing so it looks more like a
void. And we haven't even added our
glare shmears. So we should do that. We
should add our glare shmears. I'm going
to do a glare node, which I'm actually
going to isolate into its own chain. If
we isolate it, you can see the edges are
being affected the most. I'm going to
set this to bloom cuz I like that kind
of thing. And then you can just play
around with the threshold like what does
and doesn't count as a glare. But you're
going to see very importantly it's also
glaring up our original footage which
that should be locked right the
projection part. So there might be a
clean way to do this but without
thinking too hard about it what I can do
is I can set alpha on this footage such
that it's using our mask. So now you can
see we've perfectly isolated the render
before after. This is what's going to
get the glare. Let's make that really
intense. So like five times stronger or
whatever. I take my mush thing. I throw
it through a mix color with an add which
basically says take some light and add
to it not the full footage but just the
glare components. So the glare view it
before after you can set it as high as
you want. And we can also like uh
saturate it, desaturate it, make it like
red just to compare original footage
composite original footage composite.
You can't pretend like it doesn't fit in
better. And there's so much more we can
do to like match um lighting or
whatever. But I think one thing that
would help a lot is the transition
between these. So, I'm talking not
really about the edge here. The first
part of the footage where it goes from
render to projection that could blend in
a bit better. What I suggest is we take
our projection, which we already have a
mask for, but I want to isolate just the
boundary over here. So, I'm going to do
a erode dilate. What that does is it
lets you dilate, in other words, make
bigger, or erode, in other words, make
smaller. I'm going to take the original
mat and subtract away the shrunk
version, which gives us the edge. I took
the thing, got rid of the stuff in the
middle, now it's the edge. subtract the
dilate erode version. I would recommend
setting this to feather or something.
And now we can do any kind of edit to
this area, which remember is the
projection area. Maybe before we add the
glare or whatever. One thing I can do is
I can run a hue saturation value which
lets me saturate. It lets me do
whatever. But I'm going to do it only on
this area, this mask, which is the
factor. So now if I saturate it, you can
see it's only on those edges. And I'm
going to dilate a bit more so that it
eats more into this. I think bumping up
the saturation is nice even if it's a
bit crispy and maybe bringing down the
value. Change the hue. So before and
after just a bit of a integration. And
then if you want the the compositor
nightmare the the mark of a novice is
take lens distortion throw it over the
entire thing. Boom. Now it distorts as
one which in a way makes it look more
integrated because everything's being
distorted by the same amount. What if I
distort negative but just a little?
Something like that. Before after. I
mean that's actually quite a lot. Let's
divide by two again. I mean, this might
sell the illusion a little more, right?
And done dispersion. People go crazy on
the dispersion. They do. Really, you
should only be doing dispersion on the
render, not on the projection, cuz that
already has chromatic aberration, but
whatever. I'll add some like 0.01. I'm
talking real subtle. So, this adds a
little something something. One thing I
learned is instead of flicking between
these, one thing you can do is there's a
split node. And what it does is it lets
you transition between two things. So,
I'm going to kind of rotate it so you
can go back and forth. I don't believe
it has a controller. Does it? It does.
does have a controller. So, I put in
these two pieces of footage and this
will let me well I can just move up
here. This will let me kind of look at
this before and after just kind of
judge. If I zoom in at this pillar, you
can see how much better integrated it
looks like. You know, some things I
didn't really do here is the radius of
these should be pulsing and whatever.
But I think this is like that 80% of the
way there, 20% experiment and then
refine. I hope you liked it. Goodbye.